Netflix's squid game The Challenge
hasn't had me feeling this much anxiety
since I was chosen last in every Middle
School game seriously I was a fat kid
and it was not fun yes Netflix has come
out with its own a multi-million dollar
reality show which Mr Beast did his own
version of 2 years ago so I thought it
would be fun to take a look at the
differences between all three the show
The Challenge and Mr Beast everything
from the prize money the game's rules
and whether or not any Hanky Panky goes
on in the washroom well that didn't
happen but players were a apparently
booted from the show for hooking up so
grab some calamari and lick that like
And subscribe button capitalism has
never looked so good
quation the games found in the show are
actually the 33rd iterations something
hang Jun ho discovers while infiltrating
the island for the challenge and Mr
Beast of course this is the first
production of the challenge took 16 days
to film Mr Beast 10 and if we go by the
sleep cycles found in the show version
we're looking at about 6 to S days on
the island other than the fact players
in the real squid game actually die and
I died a little inside watching some of
this there are dozens of differences
between all these versions first and
foremost the prize pool in the show the
prize is 45.6 billion W or roughly $
34.8 million us that's about
$76,000 per person when eliminated
admittedly this is much higher than the
Netflix and Mr Beast versions but then
again people aren't actually dying in
those the Netflix version has a prize
pool of 45.6 million us or 10,000 per
person eliminated and Mr Beast a grand
total of
$456,000 or 1,000 per person eliminated
one thing neither the Mr Beast or show
version have are these player processing
rooms they're almost necessary in
reality TV in order to get to know the
contestants in the show this is done
primarily through dialogue and plot
while the Mr Beast version is more
focused on the game due to it it shorten
length squid Game Challenge is the
lengthiest of the versions clocking in
at roughly 9 hours of gameplay
throughout the 10 episodes and while the
show has nine episodes not all of them
take place within the game there's a lot
of setup and plot that takes place
outside of them finally Mr Beast clocks
in at roughly 26 minutes less time also
means a leaner budget now Mr Beast is no
stranger to elaborate multi-million doll
videos in fact he claims his 26 minute
long video cost roughly $3.5 million in
contrast is the challenge where each
episode is estimated at being about a
million a piece times 10 episodes and
add the 4.56 million prize pool and
we're looking at a budget at around 15
million now the actual production budget
of squid Game the show was estimated to
be 21 to $22 million but we need to
compare the actual games within them
like imagine if Squid game from the show
actually happened in real life no doubt
that its budget would be in the hundreds
of millions not only is the prize pool
alone over $30 us million but remember
the games take place on a secluded
Island where this multi-million dollar
facility would have to be built hidden
and maintained making its theoretical
price astronomical obviously with Squid
Game the show taking place in Korea
you're going to have a predominantly
Korean cast The Challenge has
contestants from all over the world of
varying ages and some of the contestants
actually know each other such as Trey
and lean who are mother and son Mr Beast
has mainly contestants from the US and
skew much younger which makes sense
considering that's his demographic all
three versions start with the iconic red
light Greenlight game and while this is
absolutely horrific in the show version
with countless contestants losing their
lives The Challenge and Beast versions
are significantly less bloody with
contestants being rigged with squibs
that give off black ink just like a
squid although the Mr Beast version
looks pretty gross that is disgusting
now the show and challenge are pretty
hands off with the contestants as they
do their games but Mr Beast gets right
up in there with his friends and will
interview contestants while they compete
this is why in his version contestants
have a whopping 30 minutes to cross the
finish line while both the challenge and
show version are given only five at the
end of the first game 2011 remain in the
show 197 in the challenge and 232 in Mr
Beast as the game progresses we can
really see some differences in budget
with the sets just take a look at the
size difference in the main living
quarters between the show and challenge
versus Mr Beast this is partly due to
the fact that contestants in Mr Beast
version Don't actually live there in the
challenge we'll see a bunch more sets
including the kitchen worker dorms
control room and bathrooms then there's
the iconic Money Ball which fills with
cash each time a player is eliminated in
the show and challenge it descends from
the ceiling while Mr Beast just kind of
lays there on the ground perhaps the the
biggest difference the challenge has
between the other two versions is the
addition of test these are a series of
mini challenges that an individual or
small groups of contestants take part in
that can either get them eliminated
eliminate others or give them an
advantage I found most of these tests
pretty interesting but the thing I hated
the most were the amount of frivolous
eliminations that were based solely on
luck I'm talking about like a dozen
contestants eliminated through no fault
of their own like this guy who opens a
Jack In The Box that just says he's
eliminated or this dude who is randomly
ousted because someone chooses him to go
after the first game contestants in the
show are given the opportunity to leave
the game should a majority of
contestants choose to do so this makes
sense in the show considering
contestants now know that their actual
lives are at stake so not including this
in the challenge or Mr Beast version
makes sense like the show The Challenge
has players doing chores and being fed
these shitty meals out of small tin cans
making contestants hungry makes the
special meal rewards all the more
valuable there's even this chaotic scene
where a dude wins Burgers and Fries and
the entire dormatory swarms in and takes
his meal oh my no way that girl got a
full Burger as contestants march to
their second game of Honeycombs both the
show and challenge have them walking
through this mcer inspired staircase
which is not found in Mr BEAST's version
they're led to this white waiting room
which is not found in the Mr Beast
version and here we begin determining
who gets which shape to cut out in the
honeycomb challenge in the show
contestants first choose a shape only to
find out later what the objective is Mr
Beast is totally random as contestants
line up and then find out what shape
they're going to get while the challenge
has the coolest method yet four
contestants each representing a group of
players must all agree on Which shapes
their group will do if they can't agree
all four of them are eliminated this
means someone will get the short end of
the stick and have to do the most
difficult shape the umbrella and it
wouldn't be Mr Beast video if he didn't
medal in the games one of his friends
even drops a lighter so that it can be
used to heat the needle to make it
easier to carve out the shape at the end
of the second game 108 contestants
remain in the show 142 in Mr Beast and
119 in The Challenge Squid game also has
some iconic classical music including
the hide and trumpet cero I only know
this because I play classical
trumpet in keeping with the show The
Challenge includes this as well perhaps
the biggest departure for from the show
is the challenges third game which
traditionally would have been tug ofwar
both the show and Mr Beast continue with
this but the challenge shakes things up
completely with the addition of
battleships I personally like this
change because it eliminates all the
strong contestants from getting together
and completely destroying weaker teams
in tug-of warar it just makes it fair
say we got to make it fair we're all
going to die in the show version
contestants plummet to their deaths
while in Mr Beast they unfortunately
fall into a foam pit and by the end of
game three 40 contestants remain in the
show 60 in Mr Beast and 73 in the
challenge all three versions
incorporates some form of duck G the
paper flipping game the salesman use to
recruit potential contestants in Mr
Beast version this becomes an actual
game in which players who are the
quickest at flipping over a paper move
on to the next round we only get one
brief nod to this game in the challenge
when two contestants play it during one
of those mini tests the fourth game in
all three versions is marble and this
plays out almost identically in all
three with contestants having to agree
upon a game of marbles and one of the
two end up eliminated after marbles 17
contestants remain in the show 30 in Mr
Beast and 31 in the challenge obviously
30 plus people going into the glass
stepping stone challenge is too much so
Mr Beast and the challenge versions thin
out the contestant pool by implementing
games like docg and more elimination
tests choosing the order of the stepping
stone challenge is pretty similar in the
show and in Mr Beast although players
familiar with the show in the Mr Beast
version have the numbers changed to
Korean so they can't tell which numbers
are which the challenge does things
completely different by having players
pick a teddy bear out of a crane game
these Bears contain a turn order which
the contestant has to give to another
player so if you get a low number
meaning you go first something you don't
want you can give that number to a
player you don't like I got to say that
challenge did an absolutely beautiful
job at recreating this set they've shot
Ed in such a way where you can't see any
safety measures should someone fall
through the glass in the show these
glass platforms physically shatter as
contestants step on them but obviously
that would be too much of a hazard for
contestants who aren't supposed to die
so Mr Beast and the challenge Implement
these trap doors Instead The Challenge
goes one step further by making these
trap doors see- through which I liked
better than Mr Beast design Additionally
you can see contestants and Mr Beast
fall into foam pits while the challenge
maintains the illusion that they falling
into Oblivion now the show has 18
platforms players must Traverse the
challenge 17 and Mr Beast 18 although
the Beast version only gives contestants
15 minutes to cross the show 16 and the
challenge 30 the glass game ends quite
dramatically in both the show and Beast
version with players struggling to make
it to the end before the time Runs Out
The Challenge is far more laidback with
contestants having plenty of time to
make it across and as the contestants
start to th out just as in the show The
Challenge removes most of the beds
making the dormatory about as empty as
my ex-girlfriend's heart when all is
said and done three remain in the show
six in Mr Beast and 12 in the challenge
at this point in the show and Mr Beast
version it's time to go to the final
game but the challenge had to add an
additional game to eliminate even more
contestants enter the circle of trust a
game where players are blindfolded and
have to put these little presents in
front of the person they want to
eliminate but if the other person gets
gues who put it there they are saved and
the other is eliminated the boxes are
even colored black and pink like the
coffins found in the show Mr Beast even
makes his own coffins in his version by
the end of this game we're down to three
final contestants the same black and
pink Motif are used in the boxes for
their dinner attire now the dinner
segment in the show and challenge are
quite similar with this Fancy Feast
complete with steak dinner this is the
fattest piece of steak I've ever seen in
my life Mr Beast version has this as
well just not quite as elegant of course
there isn't a brutal stabbing in the
Challenger Mr Beast but the challenge
has a final elimination before two
players advance to the final round this
is a completely luck-based game in which
contestants must press a button if it's
green you get to choose who joins you in
the final gray nothing happens and red
you are eliminated and now we come to
the final game two contestants remain in
the show two in the challenge and six in
Mr Beast of course the show's final game
game is squid game itself a Korean
children's game we see play out in the
show Mr Beast decides to foro this since
no one in North America really knows how
this game is played instead they play
musical chairs admittedly not the most
thrilling final game but neither is rock
paper scissors the last game in the
challenge if you win around you get a
key that may or may not open the safe to
all the money when all is said and done
player 456 wins on the show 79 in Mr
Beast and 287 in the show both the
winners of the show and challenge are
given this gold debit card with all the
money on it while Mr Beast has this dude
sledgehammering the money making for an
absolutely terrible cleanup the
challenge also includes a brief wrap-up
of what some of the contestants are up
to after the game this doesn't happen in
the show cuz they're all dead one thing
the challenge and Beast version don't
have are the inclusion of the VIPs or a
mole while I can see why these weren't
included I think incorporating them into
future Seasons which by the way way the
challenge has just been renewed for
season 2 would add a whole new element
to the game and really spice things up
but now I turn it over to you what do
you think was the best squid game and
are you looking forward to season 2 of
The Challenge let me know in the
comments below thanks for watching be
sure to like And subscribe and for more
bad takes you can follow me on Twitter
and Instagram @ thinkstory YT until next
time remember Daddy loves you very
much